[Musique]
un fond intox avec Antoine fenaud
bonjour Antoine bonjour Raphaël et
direction l'Iran ce soir avec la preuve
incolée zinfox les fausses infos
touchent même les personnes les mieux
intentionnées oui absolument Raphaël
d'abord un petit peu de contexte avant
de développer c'est un fox on le sait
qu'il y a une réflexion violente de la
contestation qui suit la mort de Marsa à
mini 76 morts selon un décompte qui a
été fait fin septembre par l'ONG il
human right et donc c'est un fox rentre
dans ce contexte vous allez comprendre
elle est basée notamment autour de cette
publication que vous allez apercevoir
juste ici
la voici voilà cette publication ici qui
relève cette vidéo que je vais vous
montrer un petit peu plus tard ce qui
nous intéresse c'est ce qui est un cri
ici ou un père à qui avait promis à sa
fille qui danserait avec elle le jour de
son mariage et bien dans sur sa tombe
car elle a été tuée par les forces
iraniennes suite à la contestation donc
faisant suite à la mort de Marsa Amini
la vidéo je vais vous la montrer la
voici elle est voilà sans surprise elle
est c'est exactement ce que vous
apercevez juste ici elle est accompagnée
d'une d'une petite musique qui est qui
est qui n'apporte pas grand chose au
contenu donc on va donc l'homme vous la
percevez ici en train de danser elle a
accumulé cette vidéo vous la percevez
ici un peu plus de 1600 j'aime sur cette
publication et sur une autre publication
en anglais également vous voyez qu'elle
a été likée plus de 30 000 fois donc
elle a été massivement relayée
massivement virale donc pour revenir à
l'origine de cette petite vidéo je vous
ai montré on voit qu'il y a ce petit
logo ici vous voyez le logo Tik Tok avec
ici le nom d'un compte inspiration Mina
et donc ce qu'on a fait nous à un enfant
intox et bien c'est qu'on allait étaler
et bien logiquement chercher ce compte
Tik Tok compte Tik Tok que voici ici
c'est bien celui-là le problème est bien
c'est que la vidéo elle est introuvable
à faire alors d'où vient-elle cette
vidéo Antoine et bien pour s'en rendre
compte et bien il suffit comme souvent
avec les infos que je dois faire une
recherche d'image inversée on a donc
pris la vidéo que vous avez vu et on a
fait cette recherche dans ce moteur de
recherche d'image inversée qui s'appelle
Yandex et vous voyez donc on tombe ici
sur plusieurs
occurrences de cette vidéo notamment un
lien vous la percevez ici je vais le
montrer sur des comptes Instagram et en
cliquant dessus évidemment on tombe sur
une publication Instagram la voici j'ai
fait une capture d'écran mais vous
retrouvez bien le même homme qui danse
avec la même vidéo cette publication en
revanche elle elle date du 13 octobre
2021 donc pas du tout de l'époque
affirmer par le et surtout il y a des
hashtags qui doivent retenir l'attention
notamment celui-ci hashtag 78 qui est
donc c'est en langue russe et ça veut
dire 78e épisode et on si ce petit
hashtag que vous voyez juste ici à taux
à Kogi qui veut dire foyer ancestral et
bien ces deux hashtag là nous renvoie
vers une série oui absolument une série
qui est en fait totalement disponible
sur Youtube et on l'a retrouvé vous
voici à ta Hokage vous la voyez voici
ici la liste des épisodes ils sont tous
disponibles sur Youtube avec l'épisode
numéro 78 et lorsqu'on clique sur cet
épisode numéro 78 et bien vous voyez on
retombe sur la vidéo que je vous ai
montré un petit peu avant avec donc cet
acteur visiblement en train de danser
sur une tombe ce qui est effectivement
le cas dans la vidéo cet acteur il est
bien connu c'est un acteur
azerbaïdjanais le voici il s'appelle
j'ai retrouvé son profil Courban Ismail
off il a 60 ans et c'est donc lui qui
participe à cette série avec d'autres la
série que vous voyez ici montre
effectivement un homme qui s'appelle
dans la série qui s'appelle Nazir qui
est donc traumatisé par la mort de sa
fille et qui effectivement danse sur sa
tombe le jour de sa mort mais vous
l'avez compris Raphaël il s'agit donc
d'une fiction merci Antoine fenaud info
intox avec Antoine restez avec nous
prochain journal dans 4 minutes sur
France 24
[Musique]